the omicron outbreak is still disrupting
holiday travel and so is the weather
more than a thousand flights have
already been canceled for today
similar to yesterday's numbers that's in
part due to airline crews grounded by
positive covet tests the monday after
new year's day is expected to be one of
the busiest travel days of the year cbs
news meteorologist and climate
specialist jeff beridelli is tracking
your new year's forecast and jeff i'm
trying to get home to la tomorrow and it
has been a mess out west
you might actually be okay tomorrow but
come friday night into saturday
saturday's the big day that's new year's
day and there's going to be a massive
storm system so on top of all the
frustration and travel headaches we're
gonna throw this big storm on top of it
with what could be a very dangerous
severe weather outbreak with tornadoes
in the southeast and extreme cold and
snow in the northern tier estates so
let's start out by showing you the
pattern right now
and we have this big ridge of high
pressure across uh the pacific ocean and
a roller coaster if you will in the jet
stream whenever you have whenever you
have a roller coaster you know what goes
up must come down until cold air is
plunging south from canada and that is
budding heads with extreme warmth in the
southeast over the next few days about
100 record highs are possible across the
southeast and a contrast of around 100
degrees across the country so the first
round of severe weather that will
manifest from that contrast will be on
friday night so new year's eve could be
severe weather places like little rock
into memphis and then eastward from
there into nashville and then north of
that it's major snow in chicago four to
eight inches of snow but the southeast
is the big threat vlad we could see
another very big outbreak of severe
weather with some pretty dangerous
tornadoes
just another reason to netflix and chill
this new year
sounds like a good time yes exactly the
pandemic and severe weather netflix and
chill jeff as always thank you very much